Speaker 1: I've been getting more and more emails
from from you guys, from people in the audience
where folks are increasingly confused about, is
Russia making progress? Is Russia going to be
taking over Ukraine or is Russia losing?
Because anecdotally, we have, for example,
what we're going to start with today, the story
of Russia seizing the first major Ukrainian city,
which would suggest, well, yeah, it does seem as
though Russia is ultimately going to take Ukraine.
But at the same time, there are widespread
reports of Russian soldiers breaking down,
crying, surrendering in Ukraine, calling mommy
quite literally. I mean, soldiers just calling
their moms. And how could both be true? And the
way that both can be true is that on the one hand,
Russia's military is so dramatically larger
and more powerful than that of Ukraine
that there's some feeling of almost inevitability
as to the ability of Russia to make progress into
Ukraine. But at the same time, individually
there are soldiers groups of soldiers that
don't want to be there, that don't want to do what
they've been sent to do and are just bailing. And
both can be true because the conflict is becoming
so widespread and more than one thing can happen
at the same time. So bear that in mind as we
talk about this first headline. The BBC reporting
Russian troops have taken control of the key
city of Carson, and this is considered the first
quote Major city taken control of by Russia close
to 300000 people, so not a massive metropolis,
but certainly not a small town. BBC reporting
Russian forces have seized control of a key port
city in southern Ukraine. Kara Sun is the first
major city taken by Russia after heavy fighting.
Now, one week into the invasion, its
mayor, Igor Kolay, Cav colleague Kiev,
said Russian troops forced their way into the City
Council building and have now imposed a curfew on
residents, so the city appears to truly have been
taken in the literal sense of the word. Several
cities are under intense shelling. Wednesday was
one of the most destructive days of the fighting.
An investigation into possible war crimes and
crimes against humanity has been launched in the
ICC. We talked about that request earlier this
week. Russia has for the first time admitted
taking heavy military casualties. 498 troops
killed, 6500 injured. Now this This number is
not a small detail for a force as overwhelming
as that of of Russia's is relative to Ukraine's.
The fact that in a week 500, they're admitting
500 have died and remember what they admit and
the full scope of it may be two different things
they're admitting to almost 100 dead a day now.
Does Putin care about that? No, probably not. But
that is not an insignificant number based on the
military analyzes that I've seen now. One other
thing I want to point to here that is important.
In a Facebook post, Mr Colley Cav, who's
the mayor of Casone, said Russian forces
were in control of the city. He urged Russian
soldiers not to shoot at civilians, saying
there are no Ukrainian forces in the city. And
increasingly, and as I've said to you guys before,
we are when things are moving so quickly it can be
difficult to know what's true and what's not true.
There are now regularly claims of Russian
aggression against just random civilians in
multiple instances, and here the mayor is coming
out and saying they're just there are no soldiers
here. Anybody you see is a civilian. Please
don't shoot anybody. Now the counter that Russia
has already started as well. There have been
numerous calls for a week now for any able-bodied
individual to take up arms. And so the fact that
they are civilians doesn't mean they are unarmed
or that they don't present a threat
to Russian troops. That's the counter.
But the mayor of Crishon saying There's no troops
here, please don't shoot civilians. And the belief
is that indeed civilians have been killed. That,
as we told you earlier this week, a kindergarten
was bombed, an orphanage was bombed, etc..
That's the latest. There is this, you know, when
we imagine the sort of prototypical police state
kind of military rule, some of these elements are
in place. The conditions set by Russian forces
include a curfew from 8:00 p.m. to 6:00 a.m.,
only going out in groups of two. And allowing only
cars carrying food, medicine and supplies to enter
the city driving slowly, so this is quickly,
quickly taking the ambiance and that that term
does not seem strong enough, but the ambiance
of a military police state. And tomorrow on
the program, you know, for those saying, how long
could this go on? Could this be over in five days?
Could this be months? The answers are both, yes,
but there are now reports from U.S. and American
U.S. and British intelligence and foreign
foreign ministries that this could be
a 10 to 20 year conflict. Now, that doesn't mean
it would be like this for 20 years, but that it
could be one of these protracted conflicts and
we'll talk about that on tomorrow's program.